antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier bonsoir la cohabitation à
l'épreuve des questions de défense à la
veille du sommet de l'alliance
atlantique
c'est demain à bruxelles françois
mitterrand et jacques chirac ne sont
plus tout à fait il ya des nuances sur
la même longueur d'onde
peut-on entendre deux voies à paris et
ne parler que d'une seule voix à
bruxelles
nous essaierons de répondre à la
question primordiale dans quelques
instants
réquisitoire très dur procès de poitiers
l'avocat général réclame 15 ans de
réclusion contre le docteur diallo
archambault mais des circonstances
atténuantes pour le professeur mériel
roberto succo alias andré à l'hôpital
purflo est tombé du toit de la prison de
trévise sur lequel il s'était réfugié
après avoir faussé compagnie à ses
gardiens retour au calme au sénégal
après les violentes émeutes qui avaient
suivi le scrutin présidentiel est à
d'urgence et couvre feu reste maintenue
dans la région de dakar
une dixième symphonie de beethoven
elle est signée pierre henry le champion
de la musique concrète l'a créée à
partir de fragments des neuf premières
une journée supplémentaire de détention
pour marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann
marcel carton les otages français au
liban n'ont toujours pas été libérés à
54 jours très exactement de l'élection
présidentielle l'actualité politique par
véritablement dans tous les sens en ce
moment meeting déclarations polémiques
surenchère de chars mais aussi de
persuasion j'avoue que parfois on s'y
perd un peu surtout quand on n'est pas
comme moi un véritable spécialiste
une seule certitude paul amar on est
loin du cas de figure que nous avons
connue et que vous avez connu en 1981
c'est vrai l'élection 88 est très
différente de l'élection présidentielle
d'abord à cause du contexte politique ça
s'appelle la cohabitation
ensuite à cause du climat qui règne dans
le pays les français ne veulent plus une
guerre civile froide
enfin à cause de l'attitude du chef de
l'état toujours aussi miss très
mystérieux et bruyant à plaisir les
cartes en n'obtenant qu'un seul discours
le discours de rassemblement
du coup les repères classiques du campe
du combat politique n'existe plus ou
plutôt n'apparaisse pas pour être
honnête le clivage droite gauche qui
caractérisait les élections
présidentielles de 80 et qui
différenciait très nettement les
candidats s'est estompée au profit d'une
guerre de positions chacun essayant de
trouver ses marques avant même
l'ouverture des hostilités
nous allons donc essayer de décrypter
les derniers messages nous allons
essayer de les décrypter à travers
différents reportages françois
mitterrand était en bretagne aujourd'hui
le chef de l'état a lancé un nouvel
appel à l'unité et à la solidarité
nationale reportage de jean michel merck
voilà un témoignage de solidarité de la
nation quatre mois après la tempête en
bretagne françois mitterrand voulait
rencontrer victimes et responsables pour
évaluer les dommages et peut-être
accélérer le mouvement at il dit pour
que ceux qui sont dans la peine ne soit
pas délaisser une occasion pour le chef
de l'état de souligner l'union
nécessaire de tous quand il faut sortir
d'un mauvais pas quelles que soient les
options politiques
de même at il poursuivi il faut une
mobilisation générale devant le défi de
l'europe la france ne peut se laisser
distraire par les humeurs du moment
et de préciser le rôle qui pour lui
incombe au président au moment des
joutes électorales rester su que vous
êtes affirmé su en quoi vous croyez
défendez vos idées défend des vosges et
ses intérêts ils sont contradictoires
mais dépassons les quand il le faut la
solidarité et la volonté nationale non
jaune ce qui est déjà des articles dur
on voit la bénisse heures cherche mais
l'unité nationale et si moi je les fais
pas qui le fera
je vous le demande qui le fera
et quand je dis moi je veux dire si le
président de la république n'en appelle
pas à la volonté les français et de tous
les français
oui je le répète qui le fera la france
n'appartient à personne a conclu
président seuls valent d'être préservée
l'entente et la concorde nationale
pendant ce temps là monsieur michel
rocard poursuit son voyage aux antilles
le député des yvelines répète
inlassablement qu'il ne faut pas forcer
le débat en faisant passer les ambitions
personnelles avant le projet politique
rachid arhab aux antilles on sait dire
les choses clairement quand il le faut
comme michel rocard ne sera pas nous et
paul lacroix myéline est numéro 1 ou
numéro deux michel rocard n'a pas
réponse en guyane comme aux antilles où
on a le sens du message politique net et
concret michel rocard s'est plutôt fait
le champion de l'unité socialiste en
visitant cette terre française
d'amérique du sud le maire de conflans
encore éviter la question serez vous le
prochain locataire de matignon
michel rocard préfère visiblement faire
campagne sur les thèmes sérieux qu'il
affectionne
la gauche dit il a acquis une culture
réaliste de gouvernement elle doit
l'appliquer
je continuerai en métropole comme ici
dans leurs griffes françaises
ici à expliquer aux français que les
enjeux sont importants qu'il n'est pas
temps de se reposer que demain on rasera
gratis qu'il ya de l'effort pour tout le
monde que les socialistes garantie
simplement que l'effort sera
équitablement pas partagée et que les
perspectives qu'il ouvre seront
correctement décrite sans illusion mais
avec ambition et enthousiasme points un
vrai discours de leader michel rocard
tout au long de son séjour antillo
guyanais n'a pas épargné la droite
notamment sur sa positif
et puis enfin à kourou levis candidat a
vu la fusée ariane qui doit décoller la
semaine prochaine peut-être en même
temps que le lancement de la candidature
mitterrand serait ce un signe
supplémentaire de la nouvelle complicité
entre rocard est le président ou alors
côté socialiste on al'impression pas la
malle repos la marque des rôles sont
désormais bien bien arrêtées bien
définir
oui c'est sans doute l'expression qu'il
convient d'employer pour qualifier la
nature des relations entre les deux
hommes
françois mitterrand et michel rocard se
sont vus à plusieurs reprises et ont
semble-t-il mise au point un code de
bonne conduite qu'ils ont en train
d'appliquer à quoi assistons en effet à
un retrait progressif de michel rocard
et à une montée en puissance de françois
mitterrand les deux reportages sont de
ce point de vue très révélateur françois
mitterrand est omniprésent michel rocard
est de plus en plus discret cela ne veut
pas dire qu'il s'effacera totalement si
le président devait renoncer à se
représenter pour une raison quelconque
et bien michel rocard apparaîtra alors
comme le candidat naturel du parti
socialiste doit faire partie de l'accord
conclu entre les deux hommes et c'est ce
qui explique la campagne en demi teinte
de michel rocard
mes doutes il un seul instant que la
candidature de françois mitterrand à
noter que ce matin les socialistes ont
présenté leurs contres bilan du
gouvernement chirac le voici un document
de 153 pages dont la première partie est
intitulé le tour d'une politique en 80
mensonge
les socialistes accusent notamment le
gouvernement chirac d'avoir capté le
pouvoir économique
dans un autre domaine à propos des
otages il affirme que le gouvernement
s'est couché devant gordji abdallah
après avoir saboté les négociations
d'avant mars 86 fin de citation
dans la majorité en dehors des grands
meeting présidentiel dont nous rendant
compte sur cette antenne c'est
paradoxalement une élection cantonale
partielle qui met la zizanie dans le
camp de l'udf
je vous rappelle brièvement les faits
dans le canton de lille ouest le
candidat du parti républicain jean
jacques descamps secrétaire d'état au
tourisme a le soutien du rpr de l'udf et
bien sûr du parti républicain mais il
devra à fond très madame delfosse la
veuve de l'ancien conseiller général
soutenu quant à elle par le cds
depuis on sent monter une certaine
irritation françois léotard avait même
menacé de se mettre en congé de l'udf il
ya quelques jours si aucune solution
n'était trouvée
aujourd'hui l'ambiance était à la
clarification apparemment
la crise est évitée olivier lerner
deuxième sous-sol de l'assemblée
nationale françois léotard à sa tête des
mauvais jours
il n'est pas le seul le bureau politique
du parti républicain entame une partie
de bras de fer avec un de ses cousins
germains
le cds le p r a tapé du poing sur la
table et a posé ses conditions
le bureau politique du parti républicain
mandate son secrétaire général à
l'unanimité pour demander ce 1er mars
1988 devant les instances de l'udf le
retrait du soutien accordé par une
composante à une candidate non investies
par l'udf deuxième huis clos de la
journée le bureau politique de l'udf va
longuement écouté les deux protagonistes
le p r françois léotard le cds pierre
méhaignerie pour éviter la crise on
cherche un compromis à l'amiable mais
personne n'obtient gain de cause
jean jacques descamps reste le candidat
de l'udf jeanine delfosse qu'ils ne se
retirent pas mais elle devra se battre
seul tu dis dans un souci de
conciliation
pas de déplacement nationale est une
émission locale
pas de retraite badine pas de soutien
national et déplacements voilà un
déplacement françois léotard peut
respirer sans l'appui des vedettes du
cds madame delfosse n'a plus beaucoup de
chances de s'imposer
pierre méhaignerie n'a jamais caché
qu'il tenait à l'unité de l'idf cette
dernière confidence en est une
excellente démonstration il n'est pas
tombé dans l'oreille d'un soutien et
leur nom ne prend pas de clinique
oui et la caméra était là difficile
d'extrapoler mais on se demande si la
cantonale de dole il ne traduit pas
certains tiraillements au sein de l'udf
1 j'ai cru comprendre là on parlait de
repères tout à l'heure là aussi les
repères disparaissent
bien sûr les bagarres sur les
investitures existe dans tous les partis
c'est même un signe de pluralisme et de
bonne santé mais tout de même se
disputer à 54 jours de l'élection
présidentielle sur une cantonale
partielle une cantonale voilà deux camps
de quoi rendre perplexe électeurs de la
majorité
et cela peut gêner la campagne de
raymond barre qui n'apparaît pas
directement évidemment dans cette
affaire et qui n'entend pas être perçu
comme le candidat de l'udf est le parti
qui le soutient c'est l'udf et une df
divisé donc affaibli ne peut que
ralentir la longue marche de raymond
barre vers l'elysée autre interrogation
importance à 54 jours de l'élection
présidentielle les problèmes de défense
seront ils à l'origine d'un nouveau
refroidissement de la cohabitation
à la veille du sommet de l'alliance de
l'alliance atlantique qui s'ouvre demain
à bruxelles
la question est plus que jamais à la une
de l'actualité hier vous le savez le
chef de l'état s'est prononcé contre la
modernisation des armes nucléaires de
l'otan
aujourd'hui le candidat chirac a
clairement marqué sa différence sans
toutefois remettre en cause le consensus
affiché en matière de politique
étrangère
alors avant d'écouter le premier
ministre je vous propose un état des
lieux
conformément à l'accord de washington
les fusées à moyenne portée seront
supprimés en europe
mais pour les autres les fusées à très
courte portée les avis divergent
commentaires de georges bortoli elles
vont disparaître les 440 et une fusée
ss20 qui permettait à l'urss de menacer
l'europe et avec elles vont disparaître
aussi leurs petits seraient 16-12 et ss
23 elles vont disparaître les piercings
week-end que dis-je elles disparaissent
déjà on a commencé à faire des
expériences pour les brûlés dans les
silos spéciaux elles vont disparaître
puisque messieurs le corps va chauffer
reagan l'ont promis juré est signé en
décembre dernier à washington
mais ces fusées à moyenne portée
disparue les américains garderont aussi
en europe leur fusée apporter plus
courte
essentiellement la refuser lens de moins
de 500 km de portée
oui dit madame thatcher qui réclament
d'urgence la modernisation de ces
missiles lundi alors que le chancelier
kohl au contraire estiment que cette
modernisation n'est pas urgente mais
vraiment pas du tout matin à paris au
cours d'une conférence de presse le
candidat jacques chirac s'est défendu de
vouloir engager une polémique avec le
président pour lui la question de la
modernisation des armes nucléaires de
l'otan n'est pas mûre
écoutez le premier ministre ma
conviction est que sans une volonté
claire de défense des européens
il n'y a pas de dialogue d'égal à égal
avec l'union soviétique dialogue que je
suis le premier à souhaiter je vous le
dis dans la mesure notamment où il est
nécessaire à l'effort de désarmement que
nous avons et auquel ne prenons pas mais
n'oublions pas je répète que le
désarmement n'est pas une fin en soi
polémique pas la mare mais des discours
relativement différent un tout de même
alors dans ces conditions on se demande
comment françois mitterrand et jacques
chirac qui vont pouvoir parler d'une
seule voix demain à bruxelles
ils le feront si on se réfère au
scénario que les deux acteurs de la
cohabitation ont toujours écrit et joué
à l'étranger
il aurait déjà arrivée d' exprimer des
positions différentes à l'intérieur des
frontières mais quand ils prennent
l'avion pour tokyo pour la et pour
copenhague où pour bruxelles miracle il
ne parle plus en stéréo mais en mono
parce qu'ils ont tous les deux une
obsession l'image de la france à
l'étranger images toujours sauvegarde
est préservée depuis le 16 mars 86 mais
il faut dire qu'ils ont une autre en ce
moment leur élection ou leur réélection
à l'elysée une obsession tenace
attention donc aux fausses notes
merci paul sachez enfin que les gazettes
politiques fleurissent à quelques
semaines
et présidentielle voici le libéral
européen qui se veut un magazine d'idées
destinées à tous les libéraux alain
madelin précise notamment qu'au delà de
l'élection de 1988 il faut surtout
gagner le troisième tour et le troisième
tour c'est en 1992 voilà pour la
politique au sénégal nous vous le
disions dès hier soir l'état d'urgence
et le couvre feu ont été décrétés
quelques heures seulement après les
élections je vous rappelle que des
incidents violents avaient éclaté dès
dimanche soir à l'université de dakar et
dans les quartiers populaires de la
capitale sur place l'opposition accuse
le pouvoir de fraude électorale
et hier soir le principal adversaire du
président abdou diouf a été arrêtée
situation préoccupante car le sénégal
est considéré comme la vitrine de la
démocratie en afrique
jérôme boni aujourd'hui malgré le calme
apparent dakar donne une image contraire
à ce que le président diouf a toujours
souhaité soucieux face à la communauté
internationale de présenter son pays
comme le champion africain de la
démocratie soulignant la part donnée à
l'opposition dans la campagne électorale
notamment à la télévision le président
réélu doit à la veille de son second
mandat décrété l'état d'urgence
chose jamais vue au sénégal depuis 20
ans et faire arrêter les leaders de
l'opposition alors que jusqu'à présent
il se vantait de n'avoir aucun
prisonnier politique à l'exception de
quelques séparatistes au lendemain d'une
large victoire
le président sortant se trouvent
confrontés à une situation difficile
la question qui se pose dans une jeune
démocratie comme le sénégal c'est
précisément de savoir si elle peut
survivre face à la crise économique
le sénégal depuis 1979
subi différents programmes de
redressement économique sous la houlette
du fonds monétaire international et de
la banque mondiale
au plan technique c'est programmes sont
considérées comme assez réussi mais il
est évident que ce qu'on appelle leur
coût social est assez lourd pour
l'ensemble de la population
particulièrement un toit pour tous les
chômeurs pour tous les jeunes pour tous
les déracinés qui sont venus de la
brousse parfois chassés par la
sécheresse et qui s'entassent dans les
bidonvilles de la périphérie ce soir du
fond de leur geôle
les leaders de l'opposition ont pourtant
remporté une victoire ils ont forcé la
démocratie sénégalaise a montré un
visage autoritaire en italie roberto
sukkur des frais une nouvelle fois la
chronique
48 heures après son arrestation succo
qui est je vous le rappelle accusé de
plusieurs meurtres en france et en
italie a réussi à fausser compagnie au
gardien avant de se réfugier sur le toit
de la prison de trévise
situation d'autant plus incompréhensible
que le personnage place et criminel
schizophrène était semble-t-il
surveiller en permanence
le plus fort c'est que la sphère ne
s'arrête pas là marcel trillât le
spectacle a duré près d'une heure en le
foyer sous haute surveillance dans une
cellule de sécurité de la prison de
trévise pourtant vers 13h alors que ses
gardiens le conduisait à la promenade
roberto succo a réussi à leur échapper
aussitôt ils escaladent le mur de la
cour intérieure sans qu'ils aient le
temps de réagir sur le toit en petite
tenue ils narguent les policiers qui
cernent la prison quand je sentirai
lance-t-il je ferai une hécatombe de
journalistes 13h45 environ après s'être
rhabiller il se lance tout à coup dans
une tentative acrobatique mais dépourvu
de toute chance de succès embusqué
derrière le mur
les policiers l'attendent ils les
aperçoit et c'est la chute
cinq mètres plus bas aussitôt transporté
à l'hôpital de trévise
il y reçoit les premiers soins au
service des urgences diagnostic fracture
des côtes et luxation de l'épaule il
s'en est bien tiré et montois dit à tort
il est très agitée pour viol est un peu
violent mais ça n'a rien à voir avec ces
blessures d'aujourd'hui roberto succo a
dû subir une forte injection de calmants
il va être ramené en prison
interrogé depuis dimanche soir par les
policiers de trévise
il aurait déjà avoué plusieurs meurtres
commis en france ressortissant italien
il ne peut pas être extradé
c'est donc la justice italienne qui va
engager une procédure contre lui il fera
l'objet d'une expertise psychiatrique
qui aboutira sans doute aux mêmes
conclusions qu'en 1981 après
l'assassinât de ses parents
roberto succo est un schizophrène
irresponsable il sera probablement à
nouveau interné à l'hôpital
psychiatrique de sécurité de reggio
emilia
c'est de là qu'il s'était échappé en
1986 en urss le calme est toujours très
précaire dans la république d'arménie
soviétique et pour la première fois
grâce à un document vidéo amateur on a
une idée des mouvements de foule qui se
sont déroulés à erevan la semaine
dernière martine laroche joubert
des images tournées par un amateur
discrètement ça bouge en urss mais en
l'absence souvent de la télévision
soviétique jamais vu pourtant les
centaines de milliers de manifestants
descendus dans la rue à erevan la
capitale de l'arménie vendre le poids
rien ne manque ni les gestes le v de la
victoire ni les slogans tout un défilé
pour demander le retour à l'arménie
d'une province voisine
les miliciens sont là mais tranquille il
paraît se chauffer au soleil
décidément les ordres viennent de haut
monsieur gorbatchev ne s'est guère
formalisé semble-t-il d'une telle
manifestation
au contraire il a reçu au kremlin deux
écrivains arminia et leur a promis
d'envisager une solution d'ici à moi une
volonté d'apaisement avec un risque
celui de voir s'ils cèdent une série
d'explosions nationaliste en urss dont
ces manifestations des revan serait en
ce cas le détonateur mais voilà on a
appris aujourd'hui que l'armée
soviétique était intervenu une nouvelle
fois en azerbaïdjan pour contrer des
troubles anti arméniens les incidents
les plus graves se seraient déroulés à
song est une ville industrielle située à
18 km au nord de bakou ce soir le
couvre-feu vient d'être décrétée c'est
semble-t-il un cas sans précédent dans
cette région les autres faits marquants
de l'actualité
commenté par isabelle staes je sue
s'achève sa mission de paix au
proche-orient ce dernier entretient
aujourd'hui à londres le secrétaire
d'état américain rencontré le roi
hussein de jordanie
toujours pas de résultats concrets pour
l'organisation d'une conférence
internationale avec la participation des
palestiniens
violentes explosions en irlande du nord
de membres de l'ira l'armée républicaine
irlandaise victimes de leurs propres
bombes
l'engin a explosé à la suite d'une
erreur de manipulation les deux hommes
ont été déchiquetés par l'explosion
l'australie en accusation pour le
massacre des chevaux sauvages à genève
un tribunal international des droits de
l'animal condamne le gouvernement
australien que autorise de telles
pratiques considérées comme nuisibles
par les éleveurs des centaines d'animaux
sont régulièrement victimes de ces
véritables parties chat
le point mulhouse dépose son bilan
l'association de voyages connaît de
graves difficultés financières depuis la
liquidation de sa filiale pointer ses
250 salariés s'inquiètent pour leur
avenir
le point risque la liquidation
judiciaire si un plan de redressement
est pas défini avant le lendemain à
paris et dans quelques villes de
province aujourd'hui manifestation sur
fond d'opéra les offres publiques
d'achat dont on parle beaucoup
le père de schneider sur télémécanique
que provoque de nouveaux remous le
salarié de télé mécaniques sont plus
mobilisés que jamais
quatorze mille d'entre eux quatorze
mille personnes seront appelées à cesser
le travail dès demain
christophe martet les offres publiques
d'achat peuvent aussi provoquer des
bouchons
cet après midi les salariés de télé
mécaniques ont débrayé pour manifester
une nouvelle fois leur hostilité h
naître et demain ils passent à la
vitesse supérieure pour la première fois
des salariés se mettent en grève pour
cause dopé à ce qu'ils craignent c'est
que le groupe tenait à être ne réalise
une opération financières juteuses au
détriment des hommes une crainte
pourtant réfuté par didier pineau
valencienne
le patron de cheney vre qui affirme
avoir une véritable politique
industrielle
selon lui la synergie existe entre
télémécanique les merlin gerin les deux
entreprises sont des leaders mondiaux
dans le secteur de la distribution et
des constituants électrique
il n'y aura ni licenciement ni
démantèlement de la société mais bien au
contraire investissements recherche
accélérée et une ambition mondiale pour
les deux sociétés
je n'ai de ressemble tout près du but
dans sa tentative de rachat mais si
l'union financière est réalisable
il faudra encore convaincre les quatorze
mille salariés de télé mécanique
aujourd'hui l'action de télé mécanique
était à nouveau cotées à la bourse de
paris on a noté une augmentation tenez
vous bien de 47%
l'opéra est évidemment pour quelque
chose
au procès de poitiers lors du
réquisitoire a sonné l'avocat général
refuse toute circonstance atténuante au
docteur diallo et archambault il
qualifie le premier de diva de
l'anesthésique et le second de braves
types rotor avant de réclamer une peine
de 15 ans de réclusion criminelle par
contre il a demandé à la cour de
reconnaître des circonstances
atténuantes
pour le professeur mériel compte rendu
d'audience avec thierry call m ce n'est
pas au juge d'instruction d'infliger des
peines mais à nous et vous allez voir
qu'on va s'en servir
jacques paugam l'avocat général avait
prévenu il réclame 15 ans de réclusion
pour les docteurs diallo et archambault
pour le professeur mériel il laisse aux
jurés l'appréciation de la peine mais
avec de larges circonstances atténuantes
auparavant les avocats de la partie
civile avait montré la voie
le débat scientifique sur les causes de
la mort de nicole berneron n'était qu'un
règlement de comptes similaires à ceux
du service d'anésthésie du professeur à
mériel à l'hôpital claude berneron
perdent deux petites filles exprimé son
éclairement mais aussi sa confiance en
la justice de son pays à sa table
courbés sur son dossier qui lit parfois
avec difficulté
l'avocat général prenait plaisir à
caricaturer deux des accusés
diallo hyper orgueilleux mégalomane la
diva de l'anesthésique petit paranoïaque
insatisfaits lui seul pouvait le faire
entendez saboter le respirateur et
maître le professeur mériel en
difficulté archambault que jacques
paugam prononce archambault est un petit
chinois qui veut se venger d'un mandat
gribouilles timide évaporée et retors le
complice idéal
seul le professeur mériel trouve grâce
aux yeux du ministère public le seul
homme viril de toute cette affaire
le seul qui ait sauvé son honneur je le
cite aucune démonstration la salle
muette écoute mal à l'aise celui qui a
choisi de frapper au dessous de la
ceinture
dans cette enceinte majestueuse où les
échanges sur toujours tendu mais
toujours courtois un réquisitoire dont
le thon destiné sans doute aux jurés
populaires ne semblait pas la hauteur de
la gravité des peines requises à amiens
la polémique rebondit quelques jours
seulement après l'expérimentation sur un
malade en coma dépassé malade qui est
décédé je vous le rappelle le week-end
dernier
la famille du jeune homme a décidé de
porter plainte pour coups et blessures
volontaires contre le professeur millau
plainte avec constitution de partie
civile indiqué l'avocat de la famille
afin de faire toute la lumière sur cette
affaire
le sport en quelques mots ce soir en
quart de finale de la coupe des coupes
c'est du football marseille l'om
affronte les finlandais de rovaniemi
avec ses trois étrangers forster allofs
et pelé l'om est largement favori en
automobiles début aujourd'hui du
traditionnel rallye du portugal le
prologue se dérouler tout à l'heure sur
le circuit d'estoril nous n'avons pas
encore l'ensemble des résultats melancia
tente d'affirmer une nouvelle
sa suprématie face aux japonais de chez
mazda qui ne désarme pas nous y
reviendrons demain soir un événement
musical ce soir salle pleyel à paris
méthot veulent vous le savez n'a composé
que neuf symphonies or le compositeur
pierre henry qui est l'un des grands
prêtres de la musique électroacoustique
propose une dixième symphonie en
reprenant les temps fort cher à
beethoven reportage georges bégoux et
christian et rue vous entendez en
exclusivité quelques mesures de la
dixième symphonie de beethoven une
batterie de 90 haut parleurs et des
kilomètres de fils qui courent sur la
scène seul univers de pierre henry qui
nous livre le secret de sa composition
un dictionnaire beethovénien j'ai
réalisé des auteurs des fragments des
pulsations des arpèges à partir des neuf
symphonies sur le papier j'ai écrit
beaucoup de notes beethovénienne et
ensuite eh bien tout cela je les
composés il ya une continuité et une
écriture vraiment de propositions que
j'ai complètement synthétiser en studio
avec les appareils avec disons sorte de
nouvelles orchestrations
électroacoustique vous présenter devant
le public tout seul ce peu moins
avec des professionnels qui sont bougés
élections avec des filtres avec une
console qui me permet d'interpréter en
direct une oeuvre qui a demandé trois
ans de travail
balade en quelques instants la météo
comme chaque soir tout de suite après le
journal avec laurent cabrol
prochain rendez vous d'information après
mme harvey cinéma vers 23h30 le dernier
journal sera présentée par aubry et de
l'air demain dès 6h45 n'oubliez pas
télématin animée par roger zabel à 7h45
andré rossinot répondra aux questions de
gérard morin bonne soirée sur antenne 2
je vous retrouve demain à 20h bonsoir
il